(two clicks)
- Hey everybody, it's Gary.
We want to make some more tangible content
of like "how-to."
I am not the most
"how-to" person
even when I do my own stuff,
but, you know, obviously
there's so many people
that I'm working with on my own team.
And Tan and Elliot, working on TikTok,
are gonna walkthrough, now, some how-to.
For me, my added value to the how-to,
which I think is a
commodity but important,
thus we're making this video
is understanding the macro.
Which is you're gonna see some how-to,
but think about the culture
that's happening in the platform.
Think about what's consume- Listen!
Listen to see what's happening,
then you'll come up with ideas.
Listen, then ideas,
and then what Tan and
Elliot will talk about here.
So, here's a little how-to in TikTok.
(groovy electronic music)
- What's up, guys?
My name's Elliot and I'm
going to give you some hacks
on how to get started with TikTok.
So, let's do it.
One of the biggest things
in creating TikToks for Gary
is finding trends but
not conforming to them.
So what we really like to do
is find really popular TikTok Trends
that are on the come-up,
before they're ultra-popular,
and find a way that Gary's
message can fit into
that in a cool way without
completely conforming
to the trend in its entirety.
- My biggest tip is, something's trending,
don't do exactly that.
Take the trend and interpret
it into your world.
Right, if I'm selling
baseball cards right now
and there's some sort of challenge,
I'm incorporating the cards
or the wine for the marketing.
Or the thing.
So, taking control of TikTok,
instead of it taking control of you.
If you're, you know, a
lemonade stand seller
or you sell ice cream or you're a lawyer,
too many think they're forced
into having to figure out how to dance
instead of understanding
that dance trend needs
to be formed into what you do as artist.
- So a big first step
in how I create videos
is I like to go find creators
that I like and see how
they structure their videos.
So I'll kinda pull one up,
I'll jot down some notes
on how they're starting it,
how they're ending it, how
their story is flowing,
maybe how they utilize text,
how they're utilizing audio.
I would just like to
go and just break down
what I think is working
and test stuff for myself.
So I'm gonna kind of walk
you through the process
of making a Tik Tok video,
and kind of how to structure it,
how to add your text in,
how to use your audio.
The whole nine yards.
Let's do it.
So first up is utilizing text.
So, text seems pretty simple in TikTok,
but it takes a little time
to get used to on how you,
like, adjust the timing.
So usually what I'll do
is I'll type my text out.
So let's say like: "Top 5 Hats."
I don't know?
We're going to go ahead and
put that in a color block.
Add a color.
I usually, typically, do
white for the starter.
And then here's kind of
the little bit of the confusing part.
You tap the text, go to "Set Duration."
What I usually like to do is have it start
like a few frames after the beginning,
so like it really emphasizes
and pops out for the
person watching the video.
So usually I just go right here,
drag the start to a little
bit after I start talking
and then drag the end to
wherever I want it to disappear.
Next up, we'll go over the audio settings.
So, usually with audio I like
to go through my For You Page,
check out some really popular creators,
see what audios that they're using
and trends that they're using,
and I'll add that to my favorites list.
And when you add that to your
favorite list it's super easy;
you just go right back in, go to "Search,"
go to your "Favorites."
And here I have all of my saved sounds
that I have that are trending right now.
And essentially all you
have to do is press "Play,"
press the little check mark,
and boom you can go in here
and adjust your volume of the added sound.
Adjust the volume of your actual voice.
And you can even actually go over here
to the little trim icon
and adjust what part of the
audio you actually want to use.
It's really helpful.
And last thing I want to
show you guys is the effects.
So, the effects is a really great way
to play on TikTok Trends
and really just emphasize
what you're talking about.
So, a lot of times people
use the green screen effect.
So, all you have to do is
press the "Create" button
and at the bottom go over
to the "Effect Library."
So there's tons of trending
effects you can use.
You'll probably see a lot of
them on your For You Page.
But I typically love to stick
with the green screen one.
It perform pretty well;
you can really emphasize
what you're talking about.
So, I'll click on the green
screen, boom, tap away.
You can actually go right here
and swipe through all the
pictures you want to use.
So, let's say for example,
I want to use this.
Here's a picture of me.
And you can just start recording.
Talk about what you want to.
It's super cool.
(chill electronic music)
- Hey, it's Tan.
I'm going to go over
repurposing content for TikTok
and also how team Garyvee
edits on Premiere.
The first thing I look at is understanding
what people are talking about.
I live and die on the Discover
Page and the For You Page.
And when I click on the
Discover Page I'm looking
at current trends.
More importantly, I'm actually
watching all the videos
to see what kind of trends they are
and how Gary's content can
fit into that conversation.
One of the most important parts is looking
for how recent the videos
are posted on that trend.
In this case we're gonna
look at the How-to Trend.
From there I actually hop
onto search.garyvaynerchuk.com
or YouTube.com/garyvee to
search for specific videos.
I'm looking for content of, for example,
"how to find sports cars" or
"how to sell sports cars online."
When I'm watching these
long-form videos I'm looking
for sub-six second moments where
I really physically
want to be in that room.
And from there and I'll cut it.
Next, I'll open up Premiere
and make sure 1080x1920.
I'll use the TikTok creative guide,
so that way all my text emojis and gifs
are inside the frame.
One tip and trick is I use Photoshop files
to create the text so
that way it looks native.
And the cool thing about
Photoshop and Premiere
is you can drag the Photoshop file
into Premiere and it works.
A couple of tips and tricks.
I really focus on the first three seconds.
Am I telling the audience
why they should watch it or what's useful
or entertaining about this video?
I'll make sure that I title it in a way
where people understand
what is exactly going on.
- P.S. before you get out.
Psst.
Leaving comments at scale.
And not spam.
Like, "Follow me!"
But like literally consuming 150 posts
and then leaving a comment
with your two cents on it.
Is a very big deal on TikTok.
(swiping)
- So that's the quick-start
guide for TikTok.
I hope you guys learned something.
(swiping)
- If you enjoyed that
and you got value from it
and it's something you think
I should double down on,
please leave a comment
and let me know what you got out of it
and do you want to see
more content like this
from our universe?
Hope everybody's super well.
Hey, everybody on YouTube,
first of all thank you so
much, so humbled for your time.
Hope you got some value out of that.
There's a plenty more
where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.